be proud of what you do a lot of
entrepreneurs they create a product or
service and put it out on the market and
and they're too afraid to show it to
people because they're not actually
proud of what they're doing you know you
need to be able to create something that
means something here that if you show it
to your mom your grandfather your
husband or your wife your kids you feel
like men I'm proud that I did this I
made this this is part of my lasting
legacy and if your product or service
isn't that good yet well you're not
willing to share that yet then you need
to go back and retool it you gotta work
to make it better and better and better
you know a recent examples you guys
watch my youtube channel is the 50 cent
video that i made i was sharing his top
10 rules and tips for success and we
spent over eight hours of research on
that video forget about the editing and
the publishing and all the other work
just eight hours of research and my team
spent five which is longer than usual i
think and they sent it to me and it
still wasn't good enough you know I
wasn't proud of the product that we were
releasing and so so this isn't this
isn't good i have to redo it and i threw
away i would say half of the clips that
they gave me and i spent the next three
hours of my evening putting together
that clips who would have something to
release for you guys and that's not
putting my team down you know they
usually do a fantastic job just I wasn't
proud of what we had created and didn't
want that to have my name on it coming
out cuz I care about you guys and 11
deliver an amazing product I want Mike I
want Hayden you know my six-year-old son
if you look at that video and and be
proud of what his father created I want
to be able to show it to my mom and show
it to my wife
and one of the things that we talked
about internally is that's a really cool
street check this out New Orleans
one of the things that we talked about
internally is I want to be able to make
a video so good if I'm profiling
somebody else that they are proud of it
too that I'm not just doing one proud
but if they saw it if I do a video on
Oprah or Richard Branson or or Howard
Schultz said they saw they be proud of
it and we're making a 50 cent video the
funny thing is once we released it
somehow it got to him he loved it and he
shared it right I went on his blog one
on his Twitter feed went on his Facebook
feed and you know blew up that video
blew up my day as well because it was
good if i didn't spend those extra three
hours of my time to create the video
that i felt would make the difference
then that video wouldn't have done well
and 50 cent probably wouldn't have liked
it as much and plugged in the sheraton
right that makes a quality difference
and so for those of you who are creating
your product or service spend the time
put in the effort to create something
that when you look at it you feel proud
you feel brimming with joy you can't
wait to show people what you've made
because until you get it to that level
it's not going to go anywhere all right
be proud of your product proud of your
service stand up for what's right
talk to you live from New Orleans love
to know what you guys think what are you
proud of question the day what are you
proud of in your business leave in the
comments below continue to believe I'll
see you guys soon